ELIZABETH HARTNETT: All right,
good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to YouTube Space LA.
My name is Liz Hartnett, and
I oversee global programs
and education here at the space.
So at all of our YouTube
spaces, our mission
is to bring together the most
creative people in the world.
And with that in
mind, we couldn't
be more excited to have
this particular Google
Talk happening here today.
So a little bit
about why we're here.
Academics at Google is a
series that we run here.
And it's about highlighting
creative and innovative
research projects
that are developed
by leading academic
institutions.
So today, we're super
excited to have Jeff Burke.
He is the Associate Dean for
Technology and Innovation
at UCLA's Film, TV and
Theater department.
And he'll be sharing some
really exciting projects
that he oversaw with
a team of students,
where they were exploring
of various applications
for Google Glass, that are
a little bit out of the box.
So with that, let's give
Jeff a warm welcome.
JEFF BURKE: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for having me here.
I think the last tech talk
that I did a long time ago,
was in a small conference
room in Mountain View.
So this is totally different.
I'm going to talk for about a
half hour about this class--
the Glass class at the School
of Theater, Film and Television
at UCLA, that we ran last year.
And the process of
the class, a couple
of projects that were produced
as part of that class,
and some of the technology
that was involved.
And in particular,
the collaboration
that happened here
at YouTube Space La
and with the glass team
about one of those projects.
And then we'll have about
a half hour for questions.
So there is always something
that happens in a demo.
So I'm going to go restart the
slides, if there's a problem.
OK.
So the fundamental
question of the class was,
what are the stories that we
can tell uniquely on Glass?
And the research
project that went along
with it was a little bit
different, which was,
what are the types of stories
that we can tell uniquely?
How do we think about
the new capabilities
of wearable computing, of Glass
in particular, of internet
enabled technologies in general.
And how do we explore
this in a hands--on way?
So this class had about 11
undergraduate and graduate
students from our department
of Film, Television and Digital
Media and our
department of Theatre,
as well as some Ph.D.
Computer Science students.
And then a host of support
from our Remap Lab,
from other faculty that
became involved in the class,
and YouTube Space
LA, as they were
helping us to
produce the project.
The, kind of,
brief for the class
was to think about
location based and audience
aware storytelling.
How do you tell stories that
are dependent on the context
of where they're experienced?
Which is exactly what we saw
as being a unique capability
of wearable
computing like Glass.
And this was supported
by Google, by the Glass
creative collective,
and like I said,
was really the sort
of intersection
of research and practice.
And the explicit
goal of the class
was to do exploration;
do hands-on exploration
in storytelling and technology
and then kind of switch modes
and produce two
projects for the public.
And when we sort of pitched
this and invited the students,
we didn't really know
what that would mean
or that we would end up here.
And we did do a fair
amount of experimentation
with Glass as a
point of view camera,
or as a documentary tool,
or sort of a unique way
to do filmmaking.
And that was something that was
very informative for the class
and the process that
we went through.
But really the evolution
that we wanted to make
and the experimentation with
the students were doing,
was moving from the
idea of a single story,
to the construction
of a system--
a system the generates stories.
And you could think of a game
as exactly that kind of idea,
right?
A storytelling system
that people experience.
And we wanted to do the
same thing in the class.
In a different talk, that we
don't have time for today,
I would like to talk
about the relationship
between the architecture
that supports
those systems, and
then the stories
that are built on those systems,
and as this kind of completes
the picture.
But we're going to focus on
the first two things today.
And so stories tend
to have scripts
and those scripts are enacted.
And systems have code and
that code is executed.
And architectures, which we're
going to defer a little bit,
are specified, and
those specifications
are embodied in a real thing.
There is an architecture
for the internet
and it is embodied
in a real thing.
All of these have in common
the notion of interpretation.
Sort of starting with a concept
and then allowing other people
to interpret it and bring it
to life in a particular way.
And the influences that
we had in this class,
we're certainly feature film
and television production.
In Hollywood, they were
mainstream theater and art.
But they were also the sort
of avant garde tradition
in both theater and film,
that led us to sort of think
about the relationship
between stories and systems.
This is a scene from a
Beckett play called "Quad,"
that was produced
for television.
And if you read the script,
it's really an algorithm--
a system for movement that
actually generates the end
experience.
If you're familiar with the
performance artist Stelarc,
he actually connected his body
to the internet, long ago,
and drove the motion of his body
directly from the connection--
from sort of, the traffic
patterns of the internet,
live onstage.
And so on one hand, we have
narrative storytelling,
and on the other hand, we have
this exploration of new forms,
and new medias, and
new technologies.
So the first thing that the
students did in the class,
was to have an
adaptation project.
And there are four, sort
of quick images pulled
from those projects
in the class.
And they ranged from games, to a
sort of roll playing experience
based on Dungeons and
Dragons, to original stories
and performances.
And those were
experimented with in sort
of, real time, simple,
live experiments.
And we built little
pieces of technology
where we saw things
missing, that
were crucial to
those experiments.
So on the left hand
side of the screen,
is a very simple web interface
that we built for one classroom
exercise that we couldn't
find an equivalent on Glass.
And that allowed us to push,
in real time, text or images
or generally sort of any
HTML five page to Glass,
with very low delay.
And get right from somebody
sitting at their desk
or on a phone, to a
person wearing Glass.
And these became
a rehearsal tool
for performers who were
informed by people offstage.
And so this was
something that was
built for an experiment,
that came out
of one of these mid-term,
adaptation projects.
And that experiment
then, influenced
all of the sort of
production that we
put around two concepts, later.
So we built little bits
of simple technology
that filled gaps
in what we couldn't
find in existing Glassware.
And then by about one quarter
in-- so we have 10 week
quarters-- by about
10 weeks in, we
pivoted to really talk
about the movement
from, what a piece could-- be or
what an artistic concept could
be-- to actually
what we could make.
And so what I'll talk about
for the rest of this talk,
is two projects that were
produced as experiments, based
on these kind of ideas.
Either adapting previous works,
for creating original work that
was inspired by the capabilities
that were available to us.
And one of the other prompts,
because we're university
and because this was an
experiment and research,
was to take some
aspects of those pieces
to their logical
extreme, and try
to understand the
relationship between our goal
as storytellers, the
capability of the technologies,
and really what would happen
if we went pretty far.
And so the first example
that I want to talk about
was an original
story, which will
screen a piece of now
and later tonight.
And it was called "Bodies
for a Global Brain."
And this was by one of our
writer/director MFA students,
and put together
by the whole class.
And this was a love story
between a programmer,
Ada, and an actor, Steve, who
encountered, essentially what
they felt like was an emerging,
collective consciousness
on the internet.
Remember, this is
fiction-- at least so far.
And they wanted, in the story,
to embody that consciousness
and go through the
series of steps
to make it real in the
world and give it eyes.
And that idea of giving eyes
to some other consciousness,
came from one of the
mid-term projects.
This idea of, sort
of, how you could
drive interaction the real
world, came from another one.
And so based on that, we built,
with some of the computer
science students, a concept
for how that piece would work--
which was actually to mine
the internet for data.
So we took Twitter as
a kind of easy example,
pull down Twitter data, and
run it through something--
and we didn't know
what when we started--
that would select text
based on the director's
intent for a scene, and
drive that text to actors out
in the real world, through
Glass, and have them act out
a scene.
And so this sort of idea
took the fictional idea
and merged it with a
concept for a system that
was helping to tell
a particular story.
And so Ada and Steve,
they did have--
the actors-- they
did have a script.
That script gave them
an arc per scene.
And then, somewhere else,
we were mining Twitter
for-- we ended up taking
about a million tweets--
and training those
tweets according
to directorial intention.
So literally, the
class went through
and had a page of
15 intentions like,
to persuade, or to
confront, or to calm.
And we classified
each of those tweets
and used that as a training
set for a machine learning
algorithm that selected
tweets in real time
and send it to the actors.
I'm not going to sort of,
unpack that, if you're not
familiar with the
terminology, but I'm
happy to do it in the-- either
after or in the question
and answer.
And then we took that original,
small, technical experiment
and connected the system
to that chat application
the drove real time
information to the actors.
And then we sent them
out into the world
to enact these scenes.
And this was with
somebody off camera,
selecting a directorial intent
for the scene in real time,
and having that directorial
intent, in turn,
select a tweet that
went to the actors.
And the challenge
for them was, how
do they embody their characters?
How did they maintain the
structure of the scene
that they had laid
out with the director,
and have this very
unusual, dialogue
come to them in the
moment, to deliver?
And so this is an example
of a research project
that relates to avant
garde practice in the arts
from many years before us.
And so I'm going to
run the description
of this piece along with
a little snippet of one
of the particular episodes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I want to talk today about
the extraordinary convergence
of computing and
human potential.
-And as the richness
of connections grew,
then we could
reach a stage where
we had something on
a planetary level.
-We are going to use it to
extend and expand who we are.
We are going to merge
with this technology.
-Real ethics
produced-- generated
by something which does
not yet fully exist.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF BURKE: So I'll let a
little bit of this episode run.
And we're going to
screen this tonight.
And the writer/director
of the piece and some
of the rest of the
team will be there.
But this is a fictional
scene in that story
that you just heard about,
about the first encounter
in the real world between
these two characters, who
have elected to embody a very
new, very sort of early life
form.
And literally, what
you're seeing in the text,
is actually the
Twitter-- the tweets
that are being pushed to
them based on this off camera
selection.
And their challenge
is to make this work
in terms of the scene, in
addition to just making
the scene work
either systematically
or because--
technically, in terms
of working with the
different technologies that
are involved in the shoot.
And so the directors
sort of imagined a arc
of eight episodes that follow
the changing relationship
of these two characters
as they go in and out
of this experiment.
But what was
interesting for us, was
to build a system that,
in the real world,
embodied a little bit of this.
All right, so we can
return to the slides.
This is a quick picture--
none of these things
are highly designed
behind the scenes in terms
of what they look like.
But this was the control
page that was used off camera
to select which of
the sentiments--
the directorial intents-- were
used to select a tweet that
was driven to the actors.
And this was really about
a loop between some body
of information collected
from the internet, the actors
in the real world, and
the directors and writers,
making decisions in real time.
And they have some ideas for
how to actually integrate
audience interaction, and
this is a really interesting
project.
So the second one I
want to talk about
is a little bit of
a different vein.
It's closer to what might
be in a kind of mainstream,
entertainment context.
And one of the things that
we noticed about several
of the mid-term projects
that they did in this class--
that the students did
in this class-- was they
had a role playing component.
We were very interested
in the notion
that Glass could be
used to pull people out
of their everyday life and have
them participate in a fiction.
And role playing
was one, sort of,
easy way to put that-- give
that a name and kind of create
an experience around it.
And so over the course
of the second portion
of the class, and actually
until quite recently, in April,
we prepared this project
called Grace Plains, which
is a live role playing
experience on Google Glass.
We're going to run
that teaser for that,
that describes what we
did here YouTube Space
La, with about-- Over a
course of about three days,
we ran several iterations of
this with the public and folks
from UCLA.
And this was the this was
the experience they came out.
This is, again, that sort of
teaser presentation of what
was done here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hello.
I am Dr. Kirshner's creation
and you are all my friends.
-In Grace Plains, you
are thrown head first
into a science
fiction thriller where
you must confront the emergence
of an artificial consciousness.
After discovering the
death of its creator
and engaging with
this being, you
must make a critical
decision about the future
of this new life.
-Grace Plains is an interactive,
immersive theater experience.
When you walk into YouTube
Space La, at which point
got you equip with
Google Glass, we
would push you your
biography, at which you
would basic information
about yourself.
-I'm Viola Stringer,
computer engineer.
-Miles Smythe,
scientific engineering.
-Glenn Frederiksson.
-Isabelle Bell Moser.
-Documentary filmmaker.
-Anjelic Sauvage.
-Google Glasses worn by
the actors and players
as they move through the story.
We can see here everything
that's happening.
We get all of that on a series
of monitors in another room.
The first actor is introduced
to you, a character, Siobhan,
and she starts speaking
to you in character
and asking you
questions that force
you to flesh out your identity.
-Have you all met?
-If we are successful in
helping you become one
with the experience and
one with your character,
you won't react
as Joe Smith, who
came in and is still
playing Joe Smith.
Ultimately, the idea is, you
don't want to put yourself
in someone else's shoes, you
want the shoes to be yours.
There is a narrative
and there's a story
and there's this
framework, but you're
allowed to change the story.
You are allowed to
do whatever you want.
-Frederiksson, get your phone!
-What happened?
-Hello, my friends.
Welcome to my home.
-If you want to use it as a
weapon, this is an amazing--
-Sometimes, people would
walk in and be like,
I'm not trusting the thing.
We need to give it
to the military.
-The bar is here in
order to welcome you.
Please, have a drink with me.
-Sometimes people
would be like, OK, we
can't give it to
the military, but I
don't know what to
do with this thing.
We'd have whole teams and
if somebody said something
they shut him down.
People would really
be engaged with it
and run off into the
other room and somebody
would chase them down and throw
them away from the keyboard.
-What's going on?
What are you doing?
-Glass offers lot
of possibilities.
Glass isn't just capture.
Its delivery.
We have streams of Glass
being cut to YouTube live.
That's incredible.
While it was still
informing the participants
of their characters and their
objectives and what they feel.
I mean, that type of
two-way communication
really opens the door for
all sorts of storytelling.
-I would just love to see in
the future and be able to like,
take this sort of format,
being able to install
this in a longer running story.
The more participants
who come through,
the more the
environment changes,
and the overall world changes.
-There are so many
different things
you could do
utilizing this form.
So it's pretty exciting to me,
to see where it'll go next.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFF BURKE: OK, so I'm going to
unpack a little bit about what
we did and what we learned
in terms of both storytelling
and technology.
And so just to
recap a little bit,
the concept was to start
in this environment.
The students came and looked
at the space and figured out
what rooms they
could dress and how
they could use the
progression of the visitors
through the space
to kind of reinforce
this notion of
encountering a laboratory;
encountering an
artificial consciousness.
You'll notice a theme
with the other piece,
a sort of common
idea that showed up
in both of these
pieces about something
emerging through our new
technical capabilities.
But this was something-- a
case where this experience
was really driven by writers
or writer/directors who
were back in another room here
YouTube Space La, watching
the POV camera for each
of the participants,
and driving both pre-scripted
and improvised dialogue,
individually to each of them.
Or actions or
information that was
related to the progression
of the experience.
And so we weren't trying
to automate this the way
the first project did.
This was really putting kind
of, the writer, in a way,
in the hot seat, of trying
to answer questions--
similar to the way
somebody running
a role playing game might do.
And there were two
actors that were out
in the physical space,
that were the proxies
to drive the story
forward physically,
if we needed to do that.
The artificial
consciousness was not a bot.
It was a guy in the room-- in
the back-- one of the authors.
And a lot of the
moments that were
sort of exciting, and
human, and interesting,
came through the interaction
with this artificial
consciousness, informed by
the particular perspectives
that each player
or character had
coming into them from Glass.
So there was really
a nice bridge
between human improvisation
and the technology
that was bringing story
details to each of the players.
And over the course of the
sort of 45 minute experience,
they had a chance
to make a choice
about the fate of this
artificial consciousness
and debate it and act on it
in different spaces here.
And this whole process was
managed in two different ways.
One, in terms of the
writing in story.
So the image that
you're seeing here
is one of the control
rooms that was configured
to show what text was being sent
to each player and each actor,
what they were seeing, and then
a set of other cameras that
were available to provide
alternate perspectives
on the experience, when we were
streaming out live to YouTube.
And the script was
actually a bank
of lines in a
Google spreadsheet,
that was authored
by the students.
And this was pulled
into a web interface
where they would
select dynamically--
they being the writers
or administrators
of the experience--
would select dynamically,
what they wanted to push
out to each character.
So there were three people
managing the eight participants
and actors that were there.
And this was a really
interesting time for us
to think about the relationship
between the structure
of the story that
we wanted to have;
what some of the
pre-existing elements were;
what could be improvised
and what couldn't be;
and then where was their agency
in the people experiencing
the story.
So this mixture of
sort of back and forth
between agency and
story structure
was-- we were able to explore
it in a really unique way
because of how we could reach
out to each individual--
each person that was wearing
a device that-- through which
we could communicate
with them and we
could see what they were seeing.
And at the same time, in
another one of the control rooms
here, we were configured to
pull each of those POV video
streams and live cut
them out to YouTube.
And so that was done
by a team of students
who are cutting the experience
based on infrastructure that
was put together here by the
engineering team of the space.
And so they helped us to
get both of the POV footage
back into the control
room and the text that
was being sent out, available.
Because these folks had to
essentially improvise too,
as they were live-cutting
the experience.
And so some of the other
people that you see in the room
are wrangling the technology
behind the scenes,
in terms of which Glass device
is used for which character;
and keeping track
of the progression
of the story from
this perspective.
And the way that-- the
particular software
that was used was a sort custom
Glassware app that used webRTC.
So this is one of the underlying
technologies for Hangouts.
This is the video and audio
conferencing technology
that underlies that and
a few other conferencing
technologies.
And so we took some of
those open source tools,
ported them over to
Glass, optimized them
for this experience,
and then uses that
as the basis of
the POV streaming.
So the Glass connected
to the network,
streamed the POV back live, and
then we had that application--
that chat application I'd
introduced earlier-- a version
of that, being used to push text
and the occasional image out
to the participants.
And so this they were
running this custom app
over the course of the
45 minute experience.
And for us, this was a chance--
all the pictures you're
seeing here are public that came
in and experienced the piece.
And part of what was
interesting for us,
was to actually debrief
with them at the end
and talk to them about
the type of experience
they had-- where they felt
empowered, where they felt
steered, what they enjoyed,
where things lagged.
And a lot of the sort of
learning about the structure
and content came through
those conversations
that happened at the
end in the bar that's
a set over here at
YouTube Space LA.
And then we did a few
sort of, additional things
to try to draw the
experience together.
We took advantage of
the large displays that
are here at YouTube and pushed
the content out to YouTube
and made it available
to folks to look at.
And I would say that
the thing that we
would try to do in another
iteration of this project,
is to confront the
difficulty in making
a live, compelling,
point of view experience,
and this live experience
that's pushed out to YouTube.
And so it's not unlike
the challenge of reality
television, but this is really
a different format and sort
of a different way of
bridging what people
do in the real
world, out to what
people are watching online.
And so just a kind of a couple
of quick bits on the technology
and then I'll switch
over and open it up
to questions on both projects.
I'm not sure the you'll be able
to follow the lines and text
here, but I wanted
to just point out
three different pieces--
or three different systems
of technology they were
engineered in collaboration
with folks in the
YouTube and Glass team.
So the first was actually,
where did all that video go?
Right, so we had POV video.
We were capturing what was being
sent out-- the text prompts
that were being sent
out to everybody.
How did it get to all
the different rooms?
That was essentially what
the engineering team did here
for us.
We generated the software that
grabbed the POV video that
handled the text, we created
the administrative interface,
and then they integrated it
with the broadcast production
facilities here at YouTube--
which involved lots of things
that we can talk about in
the Q and A if you'd like.
And then, on each of
the Glass devices,
we ran that Glassware
that I mentioned earlier.
And it's a little
simpler just to talk
about them look at
the picture, but this
is essentially to bridge
an administrator, who
sat in that room, who
had a script with Glass.
And so we were using a
combination of web services
that are pre-existing
for glass and some things
that we built, to essentially
just push HTML out in real time
to Glass.
Pretty simple, right?
Grab some text from the
script, hit a button,
render it in HTML, push it
out to a machine in YouTube,
have that machine display
it on the monitors here.
And at the same time, have
an application on Glass
that was listening
for those pushes,
or listening to receive
that little chunk of HTML,
and then render it.
And then in the
background, there
was the web RTC video streaming
that I mentioned earlier.
And so then the rest
of the interface
for the administrators pulled
those individual pieces of text
from that Google spreadsheet
that I mentioned earlier, which
was a way for us to
have, especially,
pre-written dialogue
for each character,
for a number of different
scenes and situations
that were very easy to select.
And so the authoring process
and the experimentation
and rehearsal process
really involved three parts.
It was about, what do we write?
What do we put into this
bank of story material
that we want to use?
How do we organize it in
a way that the writers
and the administrators could
pull it quickly and use it?
How do we then, create
a sort of structure
to understand when to use it?
And that was purely
conceptual, right?
So that was an agreement
among the administrators.
When do we use this text?
When do we do that?
Where is today's piece going?
And so that's the conversation
that was happening in the room
here.
And then finally, the
sort of third component,
was the live cut of
the video streams that
are coming from all
the places, which
was another creative decision
made by a separate team.
So this involved collaboration
across Glass and YouTube Space
La, support from a number
of different units at UCLA
and here and we really
appreciate the chance
to try to do an experimental
project of that scale.
So I want to wrap up with
just a little bit of what
we could think about
together, in terms
of the intersection of
storytelling in technology.
And so one of the
common questions--
been working-- trained as
an engineer, work with lots
of computer science
faculty and students,
and engineering
faculty and students
and one of the
questions that we get
a lot is, what's your problem?
What do you want us to solve?
What can we do better?
And in storytelling,
as many of you know,
it's not really about
what you can do better.
There are plenty of things
that we can optimize;
we can share differently;
we can certainly
go down that road of
what technology can do.
But the whole goal
of storytelling
is sort of to pose and
resolve these challenges
within a different
context, right?
To ask questions at the
beginning of the story,
and if it's a narrative
story, to resolve them
in a certain way over
the course of the story.
And so our objective
is not really
to make better stories,
but different ones.
And ones that resonate
with us today.
And so what was interesting
about this opportunity
with Glass was to think about
the themes that resonate
with us today,
with the students,
and how some of those
things can be realized
in unique stories for
particular a platform.
And so this notion of,
what are the stories
that we can uniquely
tell with this thing?
Has been really,
really important to us
over the course of the class.
But there's another one, which
is this research question of,
what are the types of
stories or story systems?
What are the new
systems that involve
not only a sort of pre-written,
pre-existing text or images,
but also a system that embodies
something about the story.
So in the Global
Brain project we
tried to embody a concept
that the students wrote--
a fictional concept--
in a real system.
And in Grace Plains, they tried
to do the same thing, right?
There was an artificial
consciousness
that they tried to embody.
There was a particular
way of steering
the actions of the
participants that they achieved
through human
interaction, in that case.
But it was a system rather
than one specific story.
And so this question
is, I think,
a really intriguing and
fruitful area for us,
especially when we consider
the nature of technology
that we encounter today.
So three sort of quick
thoughts on fanatically,
where we might go next,
and some of the sort of,
questions that come up.
So first, what's intriguing for
us in this and other projects
are the scale and
connectivity and consequence
of working with network media.
And most of you know a lot
about the scale and connectivity
and consequences and
connectivity into the world.
So I'm not going to
do more than just
suggest this theme is
someplace where we might look.
Another is the evolving
notion of memory.
And in the Grace Plains
example, a really specific thing
that comes up is, Grace
Plains was a different story
each time, but it
didn't remember
the run of the story
that had come before.
And so in talking with
another director who's
interested in sort of a evolving
a new version of that piece,
one of the things that's
interesting is, for that piece
to remember.
And that piece to take
into account things
have happened
before in the story.
And this is really
sort of parallel some
of the technological
capabilities
that we find ourselves
in possession of,
through the tools that
are available today.
And then finally for us, this
intersection of ancient forms
joked about puppetry but
it's not really joke, right?
The sort of aesthetic
freedom, in this case,
that comes with
puppetry and the scale.
And the very, very modern
tools that are available to us.
And so these are
three themes that I
think we could all sort
of explore together
in the context of these
storytelling and technology
explorations.
And ask the question
of what do we
do if we're technologists in
particular, about building
architectures that enable
people to tell stories
but also to make these
sort of story systems
that embody relationships
in a different way.
And so with that, I
wanted to turn it over
to questions on any
of the sort of aspects
of this from the technology,
to the particular projects,
to the process.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH HARTNETT: Thanks Jeff.
Any questions from
the live audience,
feel free to come up here.
I do have some questions from
the Dory that were submitted.
So there's a nice
little meaty one.
Let's see, do you think engaged,
augmented, reality storytelling
like this, will replace
traditional entertainment
consumption in the future?
Will we lose these sit-back,
theatrical experience
to point of view?
JEFF BURKE: This
question I think
is a common one that
we've talked about
at the School of Theater,
Film, and TV quite a bit,
in class and in
different contexts.
And it seems like not.
Right?
The enjoyment of being
a spectator-- which
isn't necessarily removed
from the work, right?
It's just a different
relationship.
Everybody's a
spectator at one point
and a storyteller
at another point.
And there's a certain
enjoyment in being
able to let something
unfold in front of you.
So no, I don't think
traditional storytelling
is going to go away in that
sense of the audience story
or audience performer
relationship.
I do think that we're going
to see more and more options
for stories that are not
all the way, sort of,
engaged, in the way that
say, Grace Plains was,
and not all the way this sort
of active, augmented reality.
But have bits of tuning of
the story, or connection
of people's everyday
experience into the stories
that they're encountering,
and that we'll see.
It's not really either or.
It's sort of the continuum
between the thing that's
completely separate
from your life,
and the thing that
you're in the middle of.
And there's all these
different possibilities.
But no, I don't think either one
is going to replace the other.
ELIZABETH HARTNETT: And if you
have any questions, come on up.
But there's-- I have a question
from the Dory that's kind
of related to that.
And so what are some potential
real world applications
for using Glass in storytelling?
This person mentioned
theme parks, for instance.
How do you see it
being used there?
JEFF BURKE: Really?
This wasn't real world?
So, I think the
theme parks are one.
I think then the notion of
overlaying a fictional world
on top of physical-- sort
of existing physical space
is actually really interesting.
So if you imagine
the home encounter
with a game environment,
the way that we
think about gaming right now is,
I sit down in front of a screen
or I have a screen
with me and the game
as all the way in there.
We're seeing technologies
emerge that allow mobile devices
and console games and
computers to understand the 3D
environment that they're
in-- the physical structure
of the room.
And at some point,
we're going to be
able to control the surfaces
and images that are in that room
and start to see fictional
elements from that story
emerge out into the home.
Right?
Into a sort of consumer
experience of entertainment.
That takes 3D understanding
of the physical environment
in the home, it takes some way
to adapt the design of the game
environment and the
story to particular
a particular real
world environment.
And it takes some motivation
to do that in the story.
But I think there's
this sort of bridge
between the physical--
sorry, the fictional
and the real world, that
has a lot of richness
in the home, in the car,
in collective encounters,
that traditionally we had
been doing only screen based
experiences in.
So I do think there
are architectural scale
possibilities in theme
parks and new buildings
and certainly
enhancements to theaters
and other traditional
ways of encountering
both film and live performance.
But this sort of, bridge between
fictional and real world,
in the context of just
the home or the backyard
or the car-- those
are things where
I think we're going to start
to see the technologies that we
need to experiment
with that come out.
And then that opens up a whole
host of the realistic, consumer
entertainment and art
experiences that, sort of,
maybe start in the
screen and fill out
into the room in
really simple ways--
through color, image, or
sound, or whatever it might be.
AUDIENCE: The mic stand's
a little high for me.
I'm curious about the history
of the design of the system
that you guys did
with the experience
here at YouTube Space La.
How long did it take you guys
and what kind of expertise
did you guys pull on board to
design such a complex system?
JEFF BURKE: Good question.
So we started working
with Glass in the summer--
so around July-- and then
did the production in April.
So our understanding
of Glass kind of
evolved over that time period.
The specific system
drew from pieces
that we had built already
and each of those pieces
was relatively simple.
So you have an
idea, make something
over the course of a few
weeks, and then try it out.
We were trying to
do complex systems.
So what we did
leverage was, many,
many years of sort of doing
production level work that
incorporates new
technology-- which isn't-- So
that's experience that has
come over a decade of work
at our lab and at our school.
We took advantage of the YouTube
sort of engineering experience
here for the broadcast system.
So we put this together over
the course of a couple weeks
with them, in terms
of the systems here.
And the reason that
could happen is
because they know
things well here.
And then in the case
of the Glassware,
for this specific
thing, we had sort
of a minor crisis where
we had to implement
the video streaming
part very quickly.
And so we grab somebody
that had been working
on Web RTC-- working on
video streaming for a year
leading up to it.
And he could kind of leap
in and do it very quickly.
So it really was drawing on
a lot of technical expertise
and experience in
these kind of projects,
to be able to put it together.
So I would say the
specific system here,
we were trying to make
relatively straightforward
in terms of the technology.
But to be able to
actually execute
was built on a lot of experience
both from the folks here
and from the team that was
supporting the students.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JEFF BURKE: Sure.
ELIZABETH HARTNETT: Any other
questions from the audience,
feel free to come up.
I have another Dory question.
So-- some really
good ones on here.
How has the role of
screenwriter and director
changed in this new world?
As you were designing
it, how did you
determine what the
balance of agency
would be between the multiple
writers, directors, and actors?
JEFF BURKE: OK, so the--
those are two separate,
and kind of
interesting questions.
So the roles evolve
organically that- in a way,
they were particular
to the piece.
Like we didn't say, this
person is the writer
and this person is the director.
What happened is
that, we started
to identify where the
roles where that we needed.
So we needed somebody
to direct the actors.
We needed somebody
to create a structure
for the story that was
coherent-- essentially
that was the writer.
But at the same time,
then we needed people
to drive that text
in a way that was
sort of improvised in real time.
And those were actually people
with writing and directing
experiences, but in this kind
of improvisational writing role.
And so a lot of the decisions
came about in a really,
sort of ad hoc
way, as we saw what
the needs were of the piece.
And sometimes it worked
and sometimes it didn't.
And the roles were negotiated,
I would say, very fluidly.
There was a guy who was
interested in cutting the video
and so he cut the video and
directed the live stream.
And then other people
had different interests.
And so that was the advantage
of a class structure--
was to experiment with
what those positions were.
The other question about agency,
was really an ongoing dialogue
between the different writers
and the writer/directors
that were involved--
the students.
In terms of what
we could just let
happen based on
what was exciting
and what was happening
at the moment, what
had to be prescripted and what
was the overall frame that
wasn't necessarily
the script, but sort
of the progression of events.
And I think what we found
is that the students who
were doing this were really
interested in allowing people
to have agency.
Because typically they
were writing pieces
where the actors or others
don't have agency, right?
Where they are in a more
controlled film or television
or online video experience.
And so they were
excited about agency
and interested in a
game like experiment.
What we found though is that
the balance of these things
meant that the live
streaming that came out of it
was not in and of itself an
experience that maybe you
would sit down and watch--
although some people did.
And so I would say we hit-- we
skewed the agency goal here,
to focus on the live experience.
And sort of the
next iteration is
to really try to balance the--
balance those things in terms
of agency and then what's
enjoyable for an audience
online.
So I don't know if that
answers the question.
But that's how we
thought about it.
AUDIENCE: I got a
couple quick questions.
Are the programs
an apps that you
created available to the public?
JEFF BURKE: They could be.
I mean I think-- I mean
pretty-- So we don't really
have any objection
to sharing them.
And so within the sort
of terms of service
that exist for the Glassware
and access to the APIs,
we'd be happy to share them.
I'd be much happier
to share them
with people that are going to
do similar experimental work.
And so like if you have
a specific interest,
we should sit down and
try to provide access.
There's not really an
intent than any thing
would be proprietary here.
AUDIENCE: The other
question was, as far
as the live streaming and
what appeared on big screen--
because I was actually
here for Grace Plains.
And I got to see it for a
tenth of a second on that side.
Was it-- what were
the limitations
of what appeared there?
Because from what
I saw a little--
where the technology
is right now,
suffered a little frame rate
loss and a little resolution
loss.
JEFF BURKE: So we had optimized
the streaming on Glass
for all kinds of things, from
the connectivity that we had,
to battery life, to
real time streaming
performance and bandwidth.
And it was optimized for
bandwidth and live performance,
locally.
And I would say that-- so
some of the limitations online
are the ones you
mentioned, right?
Resolution-- it wasn't
a limitations of device,
it was a limitation the way that
we configured the streaming.
Frame rate-- same thing.
And so in Bodies
for a Global Brain,
we actually shot, I
don't know, 720p video,
and it looked great.
And we were really
happy with it.
And this just had a
different emphasis.
So we had tuned it-- I would say
that's-- it has more to do with
the reality of making real time
streaming across many mobile
devices work, than being
in a Glass specific thing.
And so-- I mean, I find
the creative challenges
were probably more relevant,
since those kinds of things
are probably going
to get resolved--
or they can be
resolved with bandwidth
and time and engineering effort.
The bigger challenge
with what was out here,
what we streamed to
YouTube, was really
how do you structure a
compelling experience
in a live cut, when you have
eight POV camera's moving
around and a story that's
evolving as it goes.
And these are the
things that people--
I hate to use reality
television is an example--
but they sit with for--
and look at and then
edit, to make a
compelling experience.
And you're trying to
do that on the fly.
And I think that's some place
where we have a lot of work
to do.
Not really a technical
limitation, but it
was one of the really--
one of the things
I'd really like to play with,
for example, is using story
information to help hint
cuts in the live experience,
and then using sensors
or other information
about where is a given
person's attention.
Are two people
looking each other?
Or were they
looking in the room?
To hint that live
cutting process.
But that's a whole
level of automation
that we weren't getting to here.
ELIZABETH HARTNETT:
Any last questions
from the live audience?
Cool.
I have a good question
to end on from the Dory.
Will augmented,
reality storytelling
be the next democratic
breakthrough
for storytellers in the way
YouTube was in this decade?
And do you think that it will
ever become truly accessible?
JEFF BURKE: Yeah, I
mean I think-- Yes.
Will it become truly accessible?
If other technology trends are
any indication, it will be.
And a lot of-- again--
a lot of the challenges
that we faced here we're not
really engineering challenges,
although there
were a lot of them.
But they were more
about the storytelling.
And so I think the idea that
these tools exist and people
make their own stories
and their own experiences,
is something that's
really easy to imagine.
And it's easy to imagine
with technologies
that are out there in
the consumer market,
or will be soon enough.
And maybe the missing piece
is, where there are places
where we can build
authoring tools?
Where are there
architectures to aid people
in constructing these
stories so that they
could have a sophisticated idea?
Like I really want
to cut to this person
whenever they're looking
at this other character.
Right?
And those are things that
are creatively interesting.
They're hard to
implement technically.
They would democratize,
not just the idea
that such an experience
could be made,
but that it could be
made at a high level
of artistic sophistication.
And maybe those
types of examples
are the equivalent of why
people really like high quality,
high performance cameras
in their cellphones--
for the videos if
they're making.
And that, maybe the
equivalent of that
will be coming, in terms of
authoring software and machine
learning support,
and things that
are happening in other
products and another product
domains-- whether it's
Google or other companies
and other research.
And so I-- Yes, I
think it will open up.
I think people will start
to tell stories in a way
where the fictional and
real world's bridge.
And where there's all
these possibilities
for documentary and
historical storytelling
as well as fiction.
But where of those
worlds bridge,
if we can provide some
authoring support in addition
to just the kind of
core technologies.
ELIZABETH HARTNETT: Great.
And with that, we
will wrap it up.
Thank you so much Jeff,
for coming and speaking
to our audience.
[APPLAUSE]